ああああああ
ん
影響ですね私の方でお話したいのは今現在私が行って10分の最前線のピラミッド状態
について話したいと思います
2017年昨年の2月に
私自身がですねまぁ私のチームが行ったのがと運を用いた
これは世界初だったんですけれど
大ピラミッド含めたギザの三大ピラミッドの継続調査を行いました
おそらくこういう皆さんもですね一度は3大ピラミッドを見たことがあると思います
それはたとえばテレビで見たとか雑誌選んだとかあるいは実際に10分に行かれたこと
がある人もいると思います
私し
もうおそらくギザのピラミッドを訪れた方が1000回を超えると思うんですが
ただこの映像実際に見たというのはまぁ去年初めてドローンを用いてエコランにの
ピラミッド4500年前に作られたピザの大学や見るとカフラーを長尺なんですがこれ
が本当に
初めてだったん
ですね現在このデータを用いては私のチームというのが実証的にここから3 d で
撮影のデータというのを作り出し
ピラミッドの建造の解く鍵をですね
探していますま今日はこの話をしていきたいと
思います
まず最初にですねまあプロダクションとしてもっともっと私自身がなぜ
10分に影響3思ったのかという話をちょっとしていきたいなというふうには思います
私がエジプトに最初に入ったのは高校卒業者19くらいの
心でですねでもともとは10分ちょっと興味があったので大学受験をしたんですけれど
a 失敗してまーその後丸印象かどうしようかと考えた時に
もともと自分のへ10分に興味があったので第10分に行ってみようかなと思ってです
ねまぁフラット
ラジ分にいってまぁそれからあの
十分歓迎ずっと住んでしまったんですけれど当時ジェットに行く前に思っていた
イメージというのはおそらく20分毎帰ったことがない方は私がまあその高校生ぐらい
持っていたイメージと同じイメージを持っていると思うんですけど
まあピアントというのはですねまあ砂漠の
を中に神て切る当たられた
もう謎の象徴の古代の剣ザッツっていうイメージがあると思いますところが実際に
帰ろうに入ってメリットですね
もうそこは東京の人口を超える大都会でピラミッドペダもう町の横
になってるんですねもうそれを見てなんかもう何でしょうね幻想がザーッと国税さって
いう
あのん
かあったんですけどええかあの主人公が減速比新しい始まりかあっ s 4てょ
遺跡のが医療をしながらですねまあ
そうしていましたまたまぁ実際に該当すれば
するものですね色んなやっぱり疑問が現場からはれてきてその中で映画実際に勉強し
たいなぁというような気持ちがすごくは入りました
アーチャミアのが移動するなかで私小国よかったなと思うのが
ゲームもそうなんですけどさっきのキャッチャーてちゃんってね福祉に履けなくの魂に
出させていただいているんですけれど
一般の人々とのそのコミュニケーションの仕方というのはすごく
あの学べたところがありますがっちゃった結構難しい話したがるんですけどね
here till 分のその
おまゆるものて特にいえばアイデアをシェアするときにいかにコミュニケーション
どういう風にして自分の木専門でない分野を知らない人に
話をするかというのはまたのこの間を飛びに曲がっていたんじゃないなぁと思っ思い
ます
ば移動しながらまぁ実際に勉強したいなということでその時に人生奨学金話を自分の
調子やた a 中の間産地
そしてその妻えみさんって言う
2位に奨学金の話を本当にいただいて常非常にありがたかったんですけどそこで実際
なぁの奨学金を得て
大学で勉強することができました
やっぱり自分の人生を振り返ったときに思うのが
まあ
こういった二山の大ピラミッドの調査なんかもそうなんですけれど
メールレベル1の豪炎でまだ自身は生かされてきたんだなというふうに思っています
もう一つ重要な縁というのが実際に大学を卒業したあとあったんですが大学を卒業した
あと
ゲージの白磁長とた会に加わったんですけど
その発掘調査大変加わったのが私の負けリアの先生でもある
アメリカ人高校学者のマークレイナーという
ピラミッド研究のこれは世界的な大臣へ日姉超コダーイ正氏
n 4 u ki 思いっきパティニョ
足跡ではなく4500年版22件の本当に痕跡を見つけそこへなが修道
実証的な考古学者になり今まリアルで研究の大家ということであります
彼自身が一番最初の研究をしたというのはまさにスピリッツでスピークスを
菅誰もまだしっかりと計測実測しなかったですね
考古学の仕事っていうのは何か物を見つけるのが仕事という風にイメージがあると思う
んですが
私たちの仕事っていうのは実は庫内を記録することです
記録によって言える幻想申請というのお話
そこから
本当の人間のある種時代さっていうのでいるわけです
やっぱりこうイメージが投影されたものっていうのはそこに何かを手に入っちゃうんで
いろんなものが変わっていくんですがそういったものを話すのが私たちの仕事なんです
ね
皆先生はそれをし pinks で行ったんですが2両今私はピラミッドで
やろって教えますこれもすごく驚かれるんですけど
この世界に最も有名な古代の建造物の位置し即ずって実はないんですよこやま
これ石一つ一つを広くしたものがない
それを今私たちを声はをします特にないのはですねこれはピラミッドのいっしよ3
コードすべきぞという内部の作り方というわけじゃないです
例えば気楽ではどうやって食べるかな勝って4ものすごい雪がありますね
で雪が
理由というのはこれはデータがないので雪が作品1050立つ
その場合にピラミッドピューマまっすぐ石が積まれているのかあるいはピラミッドの中
にはコアと呼ばれる大きな階段状のものがあるのかあるいは
レイヤー上になっているこれを知るためにはやっぱりピラミッド
まあこれは実測しなければならなんですけれど
ギザの三大ピラミッドってもうほぼ完璧な貨物で6500年前のが残ってるんですね
そのために壊さないと実際に中のつけて見えないですねまぁただ実は
なびくつかの場所で平見どのない服
構造っていうのは見ることができます例えば頂上部っていうのはこれは本来の血小板と
いうのが一番最初にしてる状況にかかっていて
キャップ飛んでくれる大きなピラミッド型の石があったんですよそれがないです
そのために頂上まで登れば上から平面的に内部の構造がねぇあるいはピラミット
ラビラビでの北東の角80メートルぐらいのところに窪みはってそこまで登ればやはり
くれたところがあるのでん席上見え
ただ何度も言う通りに登らないといけないんですねそこで実際にょんですけどこれだけ
ですよね
ます
世界が違って2013年に初めてじっとに来たんですけれどもこの時にたまたまが
いろんな縁が重なって私自身もここに出演させていただくことになりました
こういった縁を
自分の中で振り替えたために自分自身が大臣
まあしてきたものが何なのかなと言うとあのコミュニケーションなんですねこれがいい
特にやっぱりメディアメディアがやっぱりこう考え方というかまぁを持ってては何です
けど作りたいのなって学術的に baku 乳してるに証言したいものがあってそれが
結構一致しなくているまた実は安泰とない話もあったりするんですけど
ただ私自身だと思うのはその中で
コミュニケーションを進めていけば最終的にお互いがいい形でこれは諦めが出ればでき
るっていうのが今までずっと私がここなってあり方なんですねそれで実際にせっかく
滋賀県観を非常に手伝ってくれて
あのー
まこりた映像を貸してくれてですね
そして実際に
この映像から学術的に3人で体だな顔
作るようなこともできたりしますこれ実際に登っているシーンですね
ドボルにどれぐらいかかった中っていうようなこともよく疲れるんですけど落ちた半
くらいかけたと思うけ
思いましたまぁそこが全部1週前図って言って
エマーそして a
ここのところでもう無く今3でもフラフラたごっこでいっちゃいそうだね
感じですけど何が一番怖かったのかけれどこの映像を通っているカメラがんですよ
世界は市や県の空ルートを登っていたんですけどなぁカメラもう
乗る前ですね
はい時36分
欲しく春パンクスけどいない今から言うのでないんですよね
いやーカメラ持ったためな植物たら大丈夫だったんですよ
まあ nerf 落ちてこずにこういう映像を撮りながら上前に持って行きました
最終的には症状までおぼってちょうど映像を撮ってそこの映像からやはり30円
メーカーというのを作ったんですけれど
ただこのデータというのが実はあまりへ
うまくいかなかったです超が私が経ってその後ろにある作り見えているのがその映像で
はあるんですけど
a
カメラでですね張梁部分を通って
あのそこから賛成データをこうしたということでこれはやっぱりあの距離も角度も足り
なかったですね
一番良いのはデータ的にはやはりドローンを用いてブローンカーピラミッドの周りと
いうのはあってこう撮影をしてハートっ
画像でガードいうのを買ってやったら成功ってそこからですね
佐治へデータを生成するというのが良かったんですが
ただエジプトでドローンこれ実は持ち込めないんですね
ナーベルでどんな事なんていうのかというとどうこれスパイ飛行
もう一今度ですね軍事的な目的に使われてしまうということで空港なんかで捕まって
そのままつい手が出てしまうんですね
a そういう話をあのー
ミーティングが募金にしていたらこれは橋7チームメンバーなんですけど私は違う
メンバーてですね
私だけで実は高校がきたなぁと
数学者とかアクションとか cg の専門家あずいろいろな人がいるよねパティ
ジョブーブよ
これに年前アメリカのなそれ中ラヴィック協会というところで世界で10人ほど毎年
マーズエクスプローラーというのを選べるんですがまぁそこには私の実際なチームがと
言っていいんですけれど選ばれてその中でですね
世界ふしぎ発見ガーがこの大症状堂っこ
どうしてですねドローンを飛ばすととか
列車でしたからで実際の超なかったのでまだ現地のあの
ドローンの会社を用いたティましたあーー結果アーサーレターああいうのを私たちが
ブーブーがこの日あこれは cg メール here 一つの石はこの
私です邦楽もサイズもすべて分かっている
世界の初めての30円の計測データということになってます
くぼみのところを話した通りにここからですね実際に同意た
ピラミッド内部構造になっているのかっていうのが分かったりしているわけです
それでは私たちが考えるような3つのあの形ではまったくなかったんですねこれが
こういった解析というのを今現在でも続けています
今ですね
リースいえば異論ベーターが集まりされます
実はピラミッド研究というのはここ数年で大きな変化形をかけます
こういったデータというのが今一つに集まってピラミッドの
形が見えてきているんですねただ今心はた人たちがやろうとしてるのはどういったこと
かというと
ピラミッドのただの建造方法ではなくてピラミッドのもっと大きな世界観
ピラミッドを作ったこの世界というのはどうだったのか
人間はどこに暮らしていてどんな組織でどんな国家
ピラミッドを作り出したのかというのを研究しています
おそらく今私だろうとしているこの30年泥勢がこのベーターの解析によってこの
ピラミッドの世界というのが
まあを少し歩いは何名ぐらいでは何とか
発表できるんじゃないかと思っていますまたこれは別の機会に発表したいと思いました
ね
fc ん迷ってくださいん
ご静聴ありがとうございました
tar